- Hello everyone.
Welcome.
I'm Stephen Pitti, Professor
of History here at Yale
and Director of Yale Center
for the Study of Race,
Indigeneity and Transnational Migration.
I'm delighted to see you all.
On behalf of my colleagues
in the Yale Program for
the Study of Antisemitism,
especially my friend Maurice Samuels
who did so much to organize
this event, I wanna welcome you
to what should be a wonderful
discussion with Eric K. Ward,
that's entitled, Skin in
the Game: Antisemitism,
White Nationalism and the Work
for an Inclusive Democracy.
Let me also thank Inessa
Laskova for her hard work
putting this event together.
Thank you so much, Inessa.
So, we have roughly an
hour here today, together.
Let me encourage everyone present
to consider putting your questions
that you have for Mr.
Ward into the Zoom Q&A
and I'll do my best to read as
many of them as I can allow,
to Mr. Ward at the
conclusion of his remarks.
So, please keep that in mind.
Eric K. Ward, a nationally
recognized expert
on the relationship between
authoritarian movements,
hate violence and preserving
inclusive democracy,
is the recipient of the
2021 Civil Courage Prize,
the first American to win that
award in its 21-year history.
In his more than 30 years
civil rights career,
Eric's worked with community groups,
government and business
leaders, human rights advocates
and philanthropy as an organizer,
director, program officer,
consultant and board member.
Eric's widely-quoted writings and speeches
are credited with key narrative
shifts in recent decades.
He currently serves
as Executive Director
of Western State Center,
as Senior Fellow with the
Southern Poverty Law Center
and Race Forward and as
Co-chair for the Proteus Fund.
Eric, thank you so much
for being with us today.
We're really excited to have you.
- Thanks.
It is such a pleasure
to be with you today.
I'm delighted to have this opportunity
to speak with everyone,
of course, the question of antisemitism,
white nationalism and
the threat on democracy.
In the front of most Americans' minds,
whether we are watching the beginning days
of a civil trial in Charlottesville
where
victims of neo-Nazis violence
from the Unite the Right riot
are seeking to hold
accountable the perpetrators,
whether we're looking at the
recent arrest and charges
of an individual who
set fire to a synagogue,
or watching with great interest
how the federal government
will proceed in its prosecution
and investigation of the
January 6th insurrection,
the stress on democracy is very real.
the rise of hate violence,
the increasing number of Americans
who believe that political violence
is the solution to our country's problems
and the answer to the
question of who is an American
and what will America
look like, are very real.
This journey started for me back in
the late '80s.
I had moved to Eugene, Oregon in 1986.
I was part of the punk movement
in Southern California at the time,
was the lead singer of a
band, a garage punk band,
ska band, that went on to
be known as, "Sublime."
But as we were attending shows,
this kind of diverse creative set of folks
who found each other in a
new identity through music,
we began to notice some of the pressure
that was happening within the music scene,
within the hardcore punk scenes.
Individuals were showing
up in increasing numbers,
who were calling themselves
white power punks
and eventually calling
themselves neo-Nazi skinheads.
They were very intent on both
policing and criminalizing
those who they felt didn't
belong within those communities.
Eventually I moved up to
Eugene, Oregon in 1986.
When I moved up, right before me,
another individual had moved
up from Southern California.
He was older than me.
He was retired.
His name was Richard Butler.
And Richard Butler was a
retired aircraft mechanic,
former World War II Vet
and recently retired from Hughes Aircraft.
He relocated to the Northwest.
Not Oregon, but to a place called Idaho,
a town called Hayden Lake
and he restarted his church,
Church of Jesus Christ
Christian-Aryan Nations.
The Aryan Nations taught three things.
The first was that Jews are
the literal children of Satan.
The second was that People of Color
were referred to a subhuman, chattel,
meaning humans without souls.
And the third was that
the Aryan Nations and
Richard Butler taught
that the United States was
to be a new Aryan homeland
and that the Pacific Northwest
would be the beginnings of that
white revolution.
It is in that period that
I first came to understand
that racism wasn't merely
a set of behaviors,
that it was also a social
movement phenomenon.
Eventually I came to understand
that what I was looking at
were the emergence of a movement
we now know to be white nationalism.
I was a young activist then
and I think it's important to say,
this was before the internet.
And as we joined together with others
to try to manage this
violence in organizing,
we collected flyers.
Those flyers for often warnings
of further violence, or harassment.
This was a period of great upheaval
by the white nationalist movement
in the Pacific Northwest.
They believed that the Pacific Northwest
was the beginnings of that homeland
and they engaged in acts of violence,
including the assassination
of a radio talk show host
by the name of Alan Berg
in Denver, Colorado,
the murder beating death
of an Ethiopian student
by the name of Mulugeta Seraw
who was attacked on his way
home one night from school
and beaten to death with a baseball bat
by neo-Nazi skinheads.
These were just a few of the incidences
that occurred here in
the Pacific Northwest.
In truth, much of what
the nation faces now,
was first experienced
nearly three decades ago
here in the Pacific Northwest.
At the time it was hard to
get the nation's attention
and in fact, until Charlottesville,
it was very hard to get the
nation's attention focused
on the fact that racism
was not only systemic,
but a social movement phenomenon
and that those social
movements actually pivoted
our understanding of what
was acceptable in society.
But these were the movements
we were monitoring.
And as we were collecting those flyers
I was telling you about, we
began to notice something.
Those who had done this work before us,
began to point this out,
that all the fliers,
no matter how overtly racist,
anti-Black, or anti-Latino,
or no matter how
anti-Muslim, or homophobic,
or anti-immigrant,
there was always some
antisemitic caricature
of a Jewish figure, or
symbol on these flyers.
It didn't matter whether
they were attacking
those who have been
diagnosed with HIV/Aids.
It didn't matter whether
they're going after immigrants,
or the media, or African
Americans, or Latinos, or women,
there was always this caricature.
And it is when we began to
understand one simple truth,
which was, antisemitism
wasn't simply at the core
of this white nationalist movement.
That it was the core of white nationalism
and that it was so central
to white nationalism
that I, as a anti-racist,
racial justice activist,
seeking Black liberation,
quickly came to understand
that we and other marginalized groups
would never achieve opportunity and equity
if we were not also active in the struggle
to uproot this form of anti-Jewish hate.
Amongst 21st century white nationalists,
Jews were being cast in the same role
that they had always
filled for antisemites,
as the absolute others,
demons stirring a pot of lesser evils
and the driving force
behind white dispossession.
As I wrote in, "Skin in the Game,"
outlining the white nationalist worldview,
at the foundation of that
movement was an explicit claim
that Jews were a separate race.
This is really critical for us to hold.
What I'm trying to
unearth here and lift up,
is that for the white
nationalist movement,
their hatred of Jews was not
a religious form of bigotry.
Jews weren't cast as a religion,
but as a separate race.
And it filled the same role
that has always been filled
by antisemites, placing
Jews has the absolute other,
demons stirring a pot of lesser evils,
the driving force behind
white dispossession.
It was an explicit claim that
Jews were a separate race,
that they weren't white
and that their ostensible
position as white
was merely a trick,
the greatest trick that
the devil ever played
in the words of the time
of a leading white nationalist figure
by the name of Pete Peters,
who was a counterpart of Richard Butler
and his Aryan Nations.
For Pete Peters and the
white nationalist group,
Jews, despite and indeed
because of the fact
that they were seen as white,
were placed as an enemy race
that must be exposed and eliminated.
It is often why I tell people
that antisemitism is core
to white nationalist ideology.
It is central.
It is their worldview.
It is that fantasy of
invisible Jewish power
that explains for white
nationalists how Black Americans,
a race of supposed inferiors,
could orchestrate the end of Jim Crow,
or how feminists and the LGBTQ community
could upend traditional gender roles,
or even how immigrant
workers in this country
could mount a challenge,
successful challenge,
to economic inequality.
Folks often asked me
over these last 30 years.
It was 30 years ago that I attended
my first white nationalist
meeting to monitor that meeting.
The reason I attended
was that, at the time,
again, we couldn't Google things.
We had to go sit in meetings.
We had to read their writings
and listened to their talks.
And I simply wasn't going to
ask people to do something
I hadn't done myself.
So, I walked into many of these meetings.
Now, these weren't the
hardcore neo-Nazi meetings.
These were the coalitional meetings
that looked much like the alt-right today.
White nationalist, tax resisters,
paramilitary figures and others
who were building the first vestiges
of what we now know to be the alt-right.
How was I accepted in these meetings?
Well, the truth is, I was accepted
because these groupings saw
Jews as their primary enemy.
Not Black people, not
other People of Color.
Certainly we were challenging
and we were trouble,
but we were placed as the puppets
of our Jewish puppet masters.
They were willing to place me
in the role of a potential ally.
In the words of one leading
white nationalist figure
at the time, Louis Beam,
he called for a new multi-racialism
within the white nationalist movement.
At least a multi-racial coalition.
In the words of one of his counterparts,
in a meeting in Estes Park, Colorado
leading up to Oklahoma City,
one of his counterparts announced,
first we deal with the federal government,
then we deal with the
question of the Jews.
That is why a multi-racial coalition
against the government is called for,
in the words of white nationalism.
Folks often ask me,
"Where is the antisemitism
"in the white nationalism?"
My response is, "It's everywhere."
When the Tree of Life shooter
said Jews were committing a
genocide against white people,
he was using language that
was intimately familiar
to his fellow white nationalists.
It is such rabid antisemitism
that is the framework
in which this entire movement functions.
But let's be clear about something.
White nationalists
don't bring antisemitism
to our community.
They merely organize the
bigotry that already exists.
Is often why I say as
an anti-racist activist,
one of the things that is
fundamental to my beliefs,
is that to refuse to deal with
any ideology of domination
is to abet it.
Fighting antisemitism cuts
off the animating force
of white nationalism
for the sake of all
marginalized communities.
In this moment,
we in this country
are dealing with two
significant phenomena.
The persistent and historic nature
and impact of white supremacy,
a system grounded on white superiority,
a belief that skin color
dictates one's place and value in society.
It is made up on an
eye on the false notion
that race is a real biological
definition, which it is not.
What we understand is that white supremacy
and the concept of race
is a social construct
largely created in order
to establish social control
in our society.
It is what allowed the
quick and fast development
of the United States into a
global economic powerhouse.
White supremacy was grounded
upon three specific principles.
The first was the stolen
resources and land
of Native people.
The second was a system of chattel slavery
that was like none other
that stripped Black people of
their language, their culture,
their religions, their very relationships
and reconstructed them
into Black Americans.
It was those hundreds of years
of free labor in this country
that positioned the United States
as the economic power it is today.
But beyond the stolen resources
and genocide of Native people,
beyond chattel slavery,
there was a third pillar
in the construction of white supremacy
and that was the control of
women and sexuality in society.
These were three critical
pillars of white supremacy.
Then along comes this
1960 civil rights movement
and this 1960 civil rights movement
overthrows white supremacy
as the rule of law.
Now, I wanna be clear about something.
I'm not saying that white
supremacy no longer exists
in America.
I can attest, as an African American male,
that it exists very much in our society.
What I'm saying, is that previous
to the victories of the
civil rights movement,
white supremacy was the uncontested lens
upon which most of us understood society
whether we were talking about
culture, politics, economics.
Then the civil rights movement wins.
It creates other lenses.
Pluralism, racial justice,
lenses of equity, right?
And it is in that moment that
those who were conditioned
to see themselves as superior
because of their skin tone,
were thrown into an existential crisis.
How could they explain that they lost
to those they saw as inferior?
That was impossible.
To acknowledge that they
lost that moral fight
would be to acknowledge
the agency and humanity
of Black people.
And that simply wasn't going to happen.
Not because people were bad,
but because they had been
conditioned in every way
to see Black people as inferior.
So, they constructed
an answer to this loss.
The construction borrowed from,
the, "Protocols of the
Learned Elders of Zion,"
a fictional antisemitic
account from Europe
in the early 1900s that was
spread by Russian secret police
who were afraid of the spread
of democracy in Europe,
particularly in places
like Germany and France.
This false narrative, steeped
in antisemitic tropes,
purported to tell a story of Jewish elders
who gathered at midnight in a cemetery
to plot the takeover of the world,
to the control of the economy,
culture, finance, et cetera.
Now, we should be clear,
this narrative was a strong narrative
because it understood that fear
and xenophobia towards Jews
already existed in society.
As I said,
white nationalists
don't bring antisemitism
to our communities.
They merely organize the
antisemitism that already exist.
Good organizers don't
try to inject new ideas
in order to galvanize communities.
They merely try to tap into the ideas
that already exist in a community.
So too was it in the early
days of the Protocols.
But it also was a strong narrative.
How strong of a narrative
were the, "Protocols of
Learned Elders of Zion?"
Well, we are bombarded with
that narrative constantly
in unconscious ways.
Not because people understand
the original narrative,
but because that is how influential,
I believe, it has been in the society.
I'll give you an example.
You don't have to read The Protocols
to actually understand The Protocols.
I often ask people if they've
ever heard of a TV show
from the 1990s, or early
2000s, called the X-Files,
produced and directed by Chris Carter.
It is a story of two FBI agents
who stumble upon a global conspiracy,
a conspiracy to infect the body politic
through the injection of an alien virus.
The aliens have made an appearance.
They're hiding amongst humans
and are slowly corrupting our leaders
and taking control of culture and finance
in order to prepare for this invasion.
And it's merely two FBI agents
who have discovered the truth
and no one believes them
and their job is to wake up
the rest of the world to this conspiracy.
If you've ever seen the X-Files,
or many alien invasion stories,
you too actually already
understand the ground narrative
of the, "Protocols of the
Learned Elders of Zion."
Now, I have to give a disclaimer here.
I'm not here to say Chris
Carter is antisemitic,
or even that the X-Files are antisemitic.
What I'm trying to help people understand
is that antisemitism
functions on a spectrum
from the conscious to
the unconscious level.
If antisemitism continues to
spread in the United States,
if the white nationalist movement
taps into it effectively,
it is because it is already existent.
It's often why I say,
there is no left, or right,
or conservative, or liberal.
Antisemitism.
There's merely antisemitism in society
and how we tap into it to build power.
And this is my next point.
We should understand
the white nationalist movement
isn't spreading antisemitism,
or even other forms of bigotry
in order to spread bigotry.
They're merely organizing the bigotry
to build political power,
to reshape the society.
Into what?
Well, let me explain.
I talked about white supremacy earlier,
a historic and present-day
system of inequality,
discrimination and exploitation,
one that still exists
in the defacto state
and was once the sole rule
of law in this country,
successfully turned back by
the civil rights movement
of the 1960s, as I explained.
I talked about how those
who believed in Jim Crow
and separate but equal,
could not accept that
they lost to Black people
because they've been conditioned
to see themselves as inferior,
uh, superior to Black people.
But the Protocols became
a very convenient answer.
For them they could state
that they didn't lose to Black
people because as we said,
in their eyes that was impossible.
Instead they lost to this
global Jewish conspiracy.
If white supremacy, the
system of exploitation,
was built upon the paper of anti-Blackness
and the genocide of Native people,
white nationalism was
written upon the paper
of antisemitism.
It's often why I say to people
that we must not conflate the two terms.
When we conflate a system
with a social movement,
it confuses us in the
tools that are needed
to respond to effectively
to each phenomenon.
I often liken, comparing,
or conflating the two
to comparing a cow in a Big Mac.
Now look, both a cow and a
Big Mac are made out of beef,
but when one drops their
Big Mac on the ground,
you don't call a veterinarian.
When we conflate systems
with social movements,
we confuse the necessary
tools needed to address both.
But there's also another danger
that we get into debates around hire.
Which one has more effect?
Well, the truth is that both
are undercutting democracy
in the society.
The civil rights move of the 1960s
through its defeat of white
supremacy under the rule of law,
brought democracy into full
life in the United States.
Now, not complete life,
so please don't be a literalist with me.
Let's understand both social movements
and conditions in society unfold and flow
along arcs on time.
What I mean, is that we understand,
in the words of John Lewis,
that before the 1960
civil rights movement,
democracy was merely an aspiration.
The advent and success
of the civil rights movement of the 1960s
evolved democracy from
an aspiration to reality.
The role of our generation is to secure
and continue to advance that reality.
But there is now a backlash, for you see,
the white nationalist
movement isn't best thought of
as a revolutionary movement.
It actually is best
thought of as a backlash.
A backlash against the victories
of the 1960s civil rights movement,
a movement that has slowly been growing
for the last four decades in this country,
a movement that has been
growing without much response.
You see, social movements
don't appear out of thin air.
You know that 1960s civil rights movement
I keep referencing?
Well, if you talk to actual historians
who may be listening on this call,
they will tell you without a doubt,
the 1960s civil rights movement
didn't start in the 1960s.
In fact, most of the major victories
of the civil right movement
occurred in the mid 1950s.
Rosa Parks, Little Rock,
Brown vs. Board of Education,
to name a few.
But even as you talk to these
academics who're well-versed
on the history of the
civil rights movement,
they will tell you something else.
That that 1960s civil rights movement
didn't get underway in the 1950s,
but in the 1930s and '40s.
Social movements grow
and influence over time.
And the mistake we have
made as racial justice
and human rights
activists in this country,
is that we have assumed
that we are the only social movements
on the game board of democracy.
That we are the only social
movements that matter.
Our own arrogance has left our communities
and in the 75 years of sacrifice
of those who came before us,
vulnerable in this moment.
You see, the white nationalist movement
understands one thing,
that a pluralist democracy
is its worst nightmare.
That a successful
democracy that functions,
that is people-centered, accountable
and transparent, undermines
the white nationalists' fear
and existential crisis, right?
What we have to understand moving forward,
is that we need to reevaluate
the importance of democracy.
I understand the cynicism.
I'm a Black man in America
and I understand the rage of mistreatment
and the incompleteness of
democracy and how it has been used
to protect inequality,
both here in the United States and abroad.
But we also have to
understand that the democracy,
that those who came before us,
sacrificed, died and struggled to bill,
has brought more to this country,
to marginalized communities
and white folks,
than any other ideology to date.
We should understand that
democracy, inclusive democracy,
participatory democracy, that
makes real this Republic,
is one of the most radical
ideologies ever in existence.
White nationalists don't
like it because the truth is,
is that the democracy
that these civil rights activists built,
has delivered more for white
America than white supremacy
and the white nationalist
movement ever can and ever will.
Democracy, for the white
nationalist movement is a threat
because it makes a lie of their argument
that race war is
inevitable in this country.
But we should understand,
if we want to know the real
threat towards democracy,
it isn't the white nationalist movement.
We have to be brave enough
to pick up the mirror
and to take a look in it.
I reflect on a rally that took place
four, or five years ago now.
Took place here in Portland, Oregon.
It was an alt-right protest.
So, counter-protesters
showed up and so did others.
At one point, as I was
monitoring this rally,
(Eric coughs)
I'm trying to understand
what the level of
mobilization was in the city.
I noticed an alt-right
activist sitting down.
And there was a guy with a camera
who had it shoved in his
face and screaming at him
and demanding that this
alt-right white nationalist
activist explain
why he was here in Portland.
Didn't he know the city of
Portland didn't want him?
Didn't he know counter-protesters
didn't want him?
Didn't he know the mayor
of Portland didn't want him
here in the city?
And why was he here, the
camera man demanded an answer.
What this white nationalist activist said
is worthy of us paying attention to.
He looked at the guy and he said,
"I've heard we're not wanted here.
"But the truth is, is
that Portland," he said,
"is a shrinking Black population
"by both percentage and whole number."
It's a true fact.
He then went on to say, "You
can say you don't want us here,
"but you're doing something
we could never get away with.
"You are actually disappearing
"the Black people of Portland, Oregon."
That was his response.
In short, he was calling us hypocrites.
You see, each day that we
allow systemic inequality
to exist in our society,
we further mark ourselves
as the hypocrites of a
pluralistic, multicultural,
multiracial democracy.
When we leave unchecked
the issues of segregation
in housing, in employment,
in education, in health,
we do the work of white nationalism.
We help lift it up as the alternative.
We are in a moment of great
populism in this country.
Very few people are
interested in the status quo.
Why?
The status quo has not benefited
the majority of Americans,
whether they are People
of Color, or white.
People want and demand
new ways of walking through society.
The answer that the
status quo is sufficient,
is not a sufficient answer.
Instead, we have to make real
the promise of a multiracial democracy.
One that people can practice
and taste each and every day.
If we don't do this, let's be clear,
people will increasingly choose the vision
of white nationalism.
Why?
It's one that everyone understands.
When I say the words,
"Make America Great Again,"
you don't have to ask
me what that looks like,
what that sounds like,
what that feels like.
We see it each and every day
and we knew it even before
the words were uttered.
But when we say inclusive democracy,
when we say a pluralist society,
we have not set visions
of what that looks like.
We have to understand,
people will pick the future that they know
even if it is unhealthy
for them, over the unknown,
nearly every time.
It's important that we
continue to move forward
to make our society responsive
and to bring opportunity to all Americans.
But the white nationalist movement
understands something else too.
That antisemitism isn't just an attack
on the Jewish community.
It is a way of undermining
belief in democracy
by providing a conspiratorial worldview
that provides very simple answers
and allows us to put our
fears onto a small community,
the Jewish community.
But it's not just in that way.
We should understand as People of Color,
immigrants and women,
that antisemitism is a much
of a physical threat to us
as it is the Jewish community.
Whether we are talking about attacks,
the mass shootings in El Paso,
targeting Latinos at a Walmart,
or the targeting of Sikhs in Wisconsin,
or the targeting of African
American church-goers
in Charlotte, South Carolina,
or the targeting of Jews in Pittsburgh,
in each case the killer
believed that they were engaging
in an existential war
with the Jewish community.
That's because antisemitism,
as I said before,
is not merely a set of behaviors,
but an ideology and a worldview.
I think I am not exaggerating
to argue that most
mission-oriented hate crimes
in the United States were
largely driven by antisemitism
regardless of who the actual victims were.
So, those of us who are
non-Jewish have to understand
that we are as much at
risk to antisemitism
as the Jewish community
is and the democracy
that we have struggled to build.
So, how do we move forward?
First of all, we need large,
vibrant, national debates
on antisemitism.
It means leaning in to
courageous conversation.
Until we as a society
start naming antisemitism
and the antisemitic tropes,
we will continue to play
them out as unconscious bias,
both individually and as a society.
Because antisemitism denies the agency
of marginalized communities
with legitimate grievances,
antisemitism becomes a convenient excuse
by those who seek to
backlash and to clamp down
on the push for racial
justice in this country.
And finally, antisemitism
provides simple answers
to the complex and nuanced conversations
we need to be having.
Understanding antisemitism
helps protect you
from the dog whistle
politics that are in play.
When we hear terms like globalist,
or Eastern establishment,
or even the media being bandied about,
those who are well-versed in
the tropes of antisemitism
understand many of the
conversations that are happening
at a conscious level.
But let's be clear, at
the unconscious level
all of us are being impacted
by these antisemitic narratives.
So, we move forward and open up the space
for discussions on antisemitism.
That means not being so
quick to treat everyone
as if they are David
Duke, or Louis Farrakhan.
It means understanding
that as we learn and
practice antisemitism,
we are likely to stumble
and make mistakes.
But if we unfairly penalize people
because of their mistakes,
we will shut down the very conversations
we need to have in this moment.
As I've said, as a
racial justice activist,
one cannot fight racism in this country
without being willing to experience it.
None can fight antisemitism,
another form of racism in this country,
without being willing to experience it.
It is the unfair burden
of moving towards a
more equitable society.
Lastly, I wanna say this.
We have to understand the
moment we are in right now.
We live in a country right now
where synagogues are being attacked.
They're not alone.
We are in a society where
they are being set on fire,
or Jews are being attacked
on the streets of the United States.
The Anti-Defamation League,
the Department of
Homeland Security, the FBI
had documented record
numbers of antisemitic crimes
being reported over the last
two years, increasingly so.
We have to recognize the moment we are in.
We can not fight anti...
We can not fight racism in this country
without also tackling antisemitism
and we can't tackle antisemitism
without tackling racism.
If the injury and the assault
on 140 law enforcement officers
on the Capitol steps of Washington DC
with little fanfare, or reaction
does not tell you what
moment we're in right now,
I fear nothing I'm going to say
in the question and answer
period will convince you.
But I will leave you with
this last final word,
your role in this moment.
When I was a kid, we grew up very poor
and by summer most I and my other friends
were out of resources and
you'll usually find us sitting
outside of the apartment
building on the lawn.
Every summer we would
remember this game we played,
called, "If I were."
And we'd sit in a circle and I went,
"If I were driving down
the middle of the freeway
"and the brakes went out,
here's how I would respond."
And we'd argue about how we'd
respond, or how we wouldn't.
What would do in that moment?
"If I found myself in lion's cage,"
dunno how that would happen,
"and the lion came out,
"here's what I would do."
But you know what question we
would always say every summer,
"If I were in the midst of the
1960 civil rights movement,
"here's what I would do."
And boy, would we argue about
what we would, or wouldn't do.
We didn't understand the
choices of our parents.
We didn't understand
what it meant to grow up
under Jim Crow, separate but equal,
the hardcore racism of the 1950s.
So, we were full of bravado
about what we would, or wouldn't do.
That question has always haunted me.
What would I do
in the midst of the 1960
civil rights movement?
You may have played similar games
with similar moments in history.
What would you have done?
Well, it occurred to
me about five years ago
that I actually no longer
needed to ask that question
and neither do any of you.
The truth is this, whatever
it is we would have done
in the midst of the 1960s,
is the same thing we are going to do
when we leave this talk today.
Make it count.
Many people have sacrificed to
bring us to this very moment.
The gateway to a multi-racial democracy.
It won't come easy.
There's no 30-minute sitcom
where everything gets tied up nice.
This calls for real work and commitment.
To save democracy, you first
have to love democracy.
To save the United States of
America, you first have to love
the people in the United
States of America.
That's what this moment calls for.
Courage, leaning in at a
time of great complexity,
understanding what is it that you will do
for the 21st century
civil rights movement.
Make it count.
History will judge you
and what you do in this moment, matters.
Thank you.
Now, let's take some
questions and comments.
- Thank you so much, Eric.
Really appreciate your
hard work here and always.
We do have a number of
questions that have come in,
so I'm gonna do my best to
send them your way verbally.
I would just remind our
guests in the audience
to please continue to
submit questions via the Q&A
if they have any for you.
One question that's come in asked you
to talk a little bit
more about dog whistling.
And you noted terms like
globalist, or the media
that have become important
stand-ins and dog whistles
for antisemitism.
And I think the question
asks, in particular,
how you think this
persistence of dog whistling,
or perhaps the new forms of dog whistling,
might change how people
think in the university,
how we think about education,
how we think about the work
that educators and students
are doing in 2021, 2022?
Any thoughts?
- That's a great question.
Look, I think we see a number of,
within the area of antisemitism,
we see a number of dog whistles
that are often put into play, right?
The idea that somehow the Jewish community
exerts more power and
control in a society,
in society.
We see that in rhetoric
across the political spectrum.
I just think last week,
or the week before,
former president,
Mr. Trump,
made a statement about how
Israel controls the United States
and policies of the United States.
Now, he said it as as a
philo-Semitic statement, right?
Seemingly positive, like when people say
Black people are so articulate,
or dance so well, right?
These seem like positive
comments, but we understand
that they are merely
reinforcing racist tropes.
So, you see this often, this
idea of invisible Jewish power
that is a significant trope.
The other is blood libel.
The idea that somehow Jews
are sacrificing children,
or the vulnerable in a
society with no care.
These are the two predominant tropes,
but there are a number of historic tropes.
I should say, for those
who study antisemitism
and who are far better experts than I,
I think it's important to
note that we all understand
that these tropes predate
the origins of antisemitism.
Antisemitism is a specific
form of anti-Jewish bigotry
and it is an ideology, but
these tropes are very active
in modern antisemitism
and it's why we need to understand them.
I think checking out out of the library,
or getting a book by a good
academic who looks through
the, "Protocols of the
Learned Elders of Zion,"
is a good place to start.
Most of the tropes are existent in there
and if we understand the tropes,
we can then recognize them
when they're in play and
we can point them out.
We have a...
For me, I understand by way of example
and then we'll go to the next question,
if someone starts talking about thugs,
I have an idea to start paying
a little bit more attention
to what they're saying
because I understand
the thug is often of a dog whistle
towards Blacks and Latinos.
In the same way we have to become literate
in the language of antisemitism.
Until we do, all of us
will be manipulated by it
no matter where we sit on
the political spectrum.
- Thank you very much.
The questions are coming
in fast and furious.
We have a question here that asks
about how white nationalists
and what this person calls,
"White right-wing populists,
do invoke the discourse
of civil rights when discussing
the supposed dispossession
"of white people, or the supposed
silence of conservatives."
Can you talk a little bit about this
and whether you see it as a cynical play,
or in some other way?
- Well, we understand from
the inception, antisemitism,
the narrative of
antisemitism, paints a picture
that Jews are seeking to
destroy European Christendom
In the United States race became
much more of a primary
identifier than religion.
So, instead of European,
the structure of European Christendom,
it became the destruction
of white Christendom
here in the U.S.
That is how antisemitism
is largely defined.
We should understand that that continues
to mainstream itself, right?
It mainstreamed itself from
the term white genocide
to the chants in streets
of Charlottesville,
"Jews will not replace us,"
to Tucker Carlson promoting
replacement theory,
which is just a retelling
of the Protocols through
antisemitic tropes.
At the end of the day,
demographics are changing
in the United States.
We are a diverse society
going through a significant
demographic change.
That creates demographic anxiety.
Anxiety to demographic
change is actually natural.
We who are on, and I put
myself on the progressive left.
That's where I sit on
the political spectrum.
This applies across
We do a terrible job of
managing demographic anxiety.
We actually tell people that
that anxiety is unnatural,
or it's bigoted.
But the truth is, all of us
experience demographic anxiety.
We experience any time we walk into a room
of people we don't know.
All those feelings you're
feeling are demographic anxiety.
We need to stop treating people
as if they are David Duke
because they are feeling
the change of a society.
On the other hand, though,
white nationalists are exploiting
that demographic anxiety.
They are telling those
who are experiencing it,
that it's not natural, right?
It's not natural to feel that anxiety.
That it's an existential crisis
and that they need to
prepare to defend themselves
against that existential
crisis by arming themselves
and preparing for a race war.
We should understand that
in the midst of great change
in a society under stress,
COVID, economic instability,
political violence, climate change,
that people will begin to believe that
unless we put forward real policies
that de-segregate this society.
It is why segregation and racial profiling
are the most significant
national security threats
in this country today.
What we understand about
demographic anxiety,
is that it can be managed.
It doesn't go away, but one
learns by putting themselves
in unfamiliar environments
over and over again.
When you have anxiety around flying,
counselors don't tell you
to stop flying, right?
What they tell you is
to start flying more,
that there's a way to kind
of manage that anxiety.
So, we have to get better
in terms of public policy,
in understanding that the current
inequality in this society
is killing American democracy.
There is no bigger threat.
And in terms of the management
of the white nationalist
group, it is racial profiling
that is the largest
national security threat.
For months, law enforcement
in DC understood
that white nationalists were
coming to that community
in an attempt to disrupt
the electoral process
of the United States.
Yet on that day, we saw them,
not in the population, you
know, crowd control, right?
We saw them in very passive stance.
Why?
Because the folks who
were marching on that day
weren't Black, or Latino.
They didn't see them as
a threat and as a result
they allowed 140 of their
fellow officers to be injured
and five people were killed.
It is that kind of racial
profiling, that unconscious bias,
that is leaving the rest of us at risk.
So, these are the issues
we have to contend with
in this moment.
Demographic change is real.
That will continue to happen.
How do we manage demographic anxiety
and how do we get our policies to deal
with the underlying segregation
that exasperates that
anxiety in that society?
- Thank you, we have several questions
that I think are essentially asking about
white nationalist leadership.
And I think there may be a
way in which some people here
may have heard you focusing on
a sort of white nationalist
leadership that might have been
somehow more community-based,
more working class.
And so, several of these
questions are asking
how you think about the
importance of wealthy donors,
the Koch brothers as
mentioned in one question
and other forms of
leadership, including people
who are actually quite
enfranchised in society
and might be pretending to
speak about those who are not,
but about whom that could not be said
applies to?
- Yeah.
Yeah, I think often we project things onto
right-leaning movements
that we would never except
from our own movements on the left, right?
We would never say that our
movements are controlled
by rich philanthropists
because we receive foundation grants.
We would never suggest
that we are being manipulated
by political elites above us.
We treat our opposition
with a level of arrogance
that is astounding to me
and doesn't speak to the real issues.
The truth is, is this,
the white nationalist movement
is putting out an effective
message and those who say
that they're trying to
create alternatives,
have failed to do so.
Now, there are lots of challenges
and there's lots of reasons
on why the white nationalist movement
has more wind than its sails.
It's not just a failure of an alternative,
but our ability to get
serious about this moment
and understand that this
is not a question right now
of economic inequality.
It doesn't mean that economic
inequality isn't an issue.
That this is an issue
of governance, right?
Who gets to belong in
society is the key question
that the other side is debating right now.
And it is not just top-down.
That is grassroots up.
We see it.
I often talk about this and this may be
what people may be speaking to.
I refer to
a professor by the name of James
Aho at University of Idaho.
In the early 2000s and I
think perhaps even till today,
he's one of the few individuals
who has done a substantial look
at the white nationalist movement.
He's a sociologist.
He published his findings
in a book called,
"The Politics of Righteousness,
"Christian Patriotism in Idaho,"
to look at the white
nationalist movement in Idaho.
And he finds some interesting things.
He finds, for instance,
that the white nationalist
movement in Idaho
has a higher level of income
than the general population
of Idaho as a whole.
That it is more highly educated
than the general population
of Idaho as a whole.
That is not unique when we look
at authoritarian movements.
Outside the U.S. we see
that same trend, right?
We should not think that because
there are more working
class, or working poor people
in these movements,
that these are poor
working class movements.
That just has to do with the demographics
of the United States.
There just happens to
be more working class
and working poor people to draw from.
The truth is, is that these
movements are disproportionately
made up of upper middle class individuals,
but they're not manipulating people
who are working class and working poor.
Instead, working poor and
working class folks are choosing
one of the few alternatives
that are being presented to them.
Look, we haven't done a good
job on the racial justice side.
We have not sent the message
that white people are
also part of our formula,
our way forward.
And until we do a better job of that,
people in the midst of
anxiety are going to cling
to whatever they believe
makes them more stable.
And in a racist society, a
society with unconscious bias,
it is going to be the movement with bias
(Eric chuckles)
that wins out in that race
unless we come up with
better, more broader visions
of what we mean when we
say America and Americans.
So, I would just say
at the end of the day,
yes, these movements are being funded
through lots of diverse sets of sources,
but I wouldn't be so caught
up on who's funding who.
I would be more focused on
building real community,
real mass-based movements on the ground
that actually speak to people's needs
and the conditions they're
living on right now.
That's what's needed.
We spend way too much time
focused on the days of the
white nationalist movement,
rather than the tools needed
to protect, defend democracy
and manage this white nationalist threat.
- Well, that's a good transition
then to several questions
that have also appeared,
which really are asking you
to think aloud, if you
would, about strategies
for the left, or for progressive people.
As people think about
building those coalitions,
as people think about speaking back about
raising fundamental questions
about the embeddedness of antisemitism
in national politics and
more folks are asking
what gives you optimism
and where you think
people's energies ought to go?
There's a question, for example,
about how we name these movements
and how we name these
struggles for justice
with antisemitism and
many other things in mind.
And others are asking
questions, for example,
about the place of labor unions and other,
at least sometimes, progressive forces.
So, could you talk a little bit about
how you think about this strategically?
Thank you.
- Yeah.
So, strategically
I would argue
that
the most powerful wind we have in our sail
is actually space and time.
That almost sounds contradictory
in the urgency of this moment.
But what I mean by this
is, we have to understand
something, I think,
really critically, right?
That this is a backlash
against
winning.
It is the racial justice movement
that is winning in this country.
Look, Black Lives Matters,
the movement in this country,
in most polling that was
done previous to 2021...
I haven't seen much pollings for 2021.
But previous to 2021, Black Lives Matters
was polling more support, by
percentage, of white America
than ever supported Martin
Luther King Jr. in his lifetime.
Black Lives Matters was
receiving more support
from white America
than the Student Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee,
the sit-ins that took
place in the 1960s as well.
Now look, we can look at those numbers
and be sad that it's not
80% of white America,
but quite frankly, we
should be more shocked
that in a society that so
socializes people to other by race
that such a significant
portion of white America
would be pulling in support
of Black Lives Matters
and that it's greater
than it was in the 1960s.
That's an arc towards
equity and opportunity
in this society.
Again, look, I didn't grow up...
I grew up in Southern California.
I grew up very poor.
I grew up through most
of junior high school
and in high school
in a motel that my mom paid
for the room by the week.
So, I'm not a big fan
of the 30-minute sitcom
where everything gets tied
up so nicely in the very end
and all the answers get
questioned, you know,
all the questions get answered
and everything's so fair and happy.
I don't know that world
and I don't think very many
people in this country,
or in this world, know that world.
To know that world
where things get tied up
so quickly and simply, is
just a world of privilege
that is beyond my understanding.
Where I live, where the most
people live in this country.
look, struggle is a part
of advancing humanity.
That's what it means.
And you know what?
It's terrible we have to do it
and we shouldn't have to do
it so hard, but we really do.
That's the job before us,
to make it easier for the next generation,
those who are yet to be born,
to continue the path towards opportunity.
This means, in my mind,
letting go of this idea
that simply because I demand a right,
that it's simply gonna be given to me.
I think it's just not
how history has unrolled
and it's not how real life unrolls.
So what, we have to get serious.
We have to understand
that we have to continue
to advance a vision verbally
of where we want to go.
We have to get very pragmatic
about those things that have been built.
We have to stop rolling our eyes.
I remember in the early parts
of the Black Lives Matters movement,
there was a great shirt.
I actually loved the shirt
'cause I'm an old punk rocker
and I like that kind of light sarcasm.
It was a great shirt that said,
"Not my Mama's Civil Rights Movement."
Folks may remember that.
I liked that shirt because it denoted
this was a new generation
that had a new set of demands.
And what was unique
about Black Lives Matters
and what is unique about
Black Lives Matters,
is that they understand the
things they are asking for
aren't (sound cuts out)
as someone told me.
These are basic rights
that shouldn't even have
to be asked for, right?
How should you even have to demand
the idea that Black lives matter?
How is that even a
controversial statement in 2021?
And so, they were very
pragmatic in understanding
that there was a very
specific conversation
that they were attempting to
generate in the United States
and I think they did so very successfully.
We need more pragmatism
like that in the left,
in the racial justice movement.
Here's the second thing.
We have to admit that we
really stumbled in this moment.
For 30 years we ignored the rise
of this white nationalist
movement and its impact.
We rolled our eyes at it.
We laughed at it.
We laughed at those who warned about it.
And we need to ask ourselves,
how did we make such a stumble?
If we can't ask and answer that
question amongst ourselves,
how are we to understand
and ensure that we don't
make those same mistakes
moving forward?
So, there needs to be much
more internal dialogue
around who we are as movements
and exactly where is it
that we are trying to go.
And until we can answer that question,
we can't expect the rest of
America to guess it for us.
But there's a third piece here.
I've often said
that the goal of the
white nationalist movement
isn't to target People of Color, or Jews.
Yes, they do because it's affective.
It's sending a message.
It's effective at creating
the political theater
that generates the conversation
they want to have in this society.
What I try to tell people all the time,
is the real target is government, right?
It's not People of Color
who are under attack.
It is the government of the United States.
It is the City of
Charlotte, the City of DC,
the City of Portland, Oregon,
the City of Los Angeles, California.
It is actually government
that is under attack.
And we have to begin to mobilize in a way
that demands that government defend itself
and defend American people.
And we don't,
we don't take that seriously.
It means also entering government,
learning how to govern,
understanding policy, the
boring day-to day-work
of maintenancing
a democracy.
It's not as fun as marching.
It's not as fun as making signs.
But it is the work that
is needed to be done
for the next generation.
We have to stop thinking
that we are the gods
that recreate society into our liking.
That is a fantasy.
That's not how the real world works.
How the real world works,
is that we invest our dreams
in the next generation
and we urgently create space
for that next generation.
And that means sustaining democracy.
And that means taking governance
seriously in this moment.
Elected board members, how
many school boards members
are running unopposed this year?
A record number.
And then we're surprised
that these faux attacks
on Black Lives Matters
under the umbrella of critical
race theory are taking place,
or that educators and
principals are being fired
for talking about the
Holocaust, or slavery.
It's because we are shirking our duties
as changemakers in our society.
We gotta get serious.
If we don't take ourselves seriously,
no one's gonna take us seriously.
We gotta stop performing
and start leading.
- Thank you, Eric.
We're gonna need to let you go.
I'm aware of that.
Let me ask you at least
one more question--
- Yeah.
- if you've got a second.
Somebody asked a follow-up question
to the question that I addressed.
I think it's trying to strike at
the question of how advances in one area
don't put to the side
important advances elsewhere.
And so, the particular
question is about how,
in activism surrounding BLM
over the last few years,
many Jewish activists and
supporters may have felt
that they became very
involved in these struggles
and helped to push for justice equity
and into police violence and
more in the very recent past.
But at a moment, virtually simultaneously
in which antisemitic violence
and antisemitism more generally
also appeared in the United States
and elsewhere in the
world, may not have felt
that Black activists,
Latinx activists and others
stood similarly with them
to contest antisemitism
in its violent and in its quotidian forms.
How do we do that work
of assuring that again
an important focus that comes on our radar
for very urgent reasons,
doesn't in turn sideline,
or eliminate from view
something like antisemitism
as it emerges and persists?
- Yeah, I would...
Quickly, I wanna point folks to an essay.
I throw my writings up
on, I think it's Medium
because of kind of a DIY from,
lets say, an old punk rocker,
so I just throw my writings there.
I just have this thought,
who's gonna publish
these writings, so I
just throw them up there.
There's one I wanna direct folks to.
If you Google my name and
the essay, "Somebody Must be Blamed,
"Antisemitism, the Equal
Opportunity Ideology,"
so, "Someone Must be
Blamed," and Eric Ward,
this fuller essay will pop up.
But one of the things that I say
that I think is critically important here
is that antisemitism is emerging
as an equal opportunity ideology.
"Antisemitism crosses every
line of race, political party,
"primary stance on a wide range of issues.
At the time, I think I said,
"Like the Corona virus,
this virulent ideology
"disproportionately impacts
the Jewish community,
"but in fact imperils us all."
I went on to say that,
"The Jewish community is
actually right to be concerned
"in this moment of populous impulses
"across the ideological
spectrum from the grievances
"that propelled a B-list reality TV star
"into the presidency to the cry of justice
"that brings throngs of
people in the streets
"in defense of Black lives.
"Historically the populous
movements have always fed on
"and in turn fueled
attacks on Jewish people."
The Jewish community
has a historical right
to be suspicious of
populism in the same way
that the Black community
deserves the right
to maintain its suspicion
of law enforcement
in this country, right?
These are historical documented
tensions and understanding.
I don't think the Jewish community
needs to say much more to us
about why it is suspicious
and concerned about populism.
Now, look, the onus is on
non-Jews to make this right
and the way we make it right
is by showing up on antisemitism.
If there are law enforcement
that I have to engage in
conversation, law enforcement,
individuals, right, not the system,
but individual law enforcement who I know
have done some thinking on race
and how it functions in a society,
have a different set of
relationships with me
than law enforcement who I know don't.
And in the same way, if we
want the Jewish community
to understand we're
serious about antisemitism,
it means we have to start
tackling antisemitism.
But I wanna say something
to the Jewish community,
in particularly those
who are white-presenting
it's simply this.
You're exactly right.
We can both be the victims
and perpetrators of bigotry
at the same exact time.
We have watched
as a disproportionate
number of Black figures
have come into the limelight,
limelight around controversies
around antisemitism.
If you understand the
nature of antisemitism
and how it functions, it's
actually not surprising
that a disproportionate number
of Black and Latino individuals,
vulnerable marginalized communities,
tend to express the most
virulent forms of antisemitism.
It's actually antisemitism
by design, right?
The purpose of antisemitism,
one of the roles in Europe,
was to create a buffer in society
between the haves and the have-nots,
so that when the have-nots got
frustrated, they were allowed
to take their frustrations
out not on the haves,
but this Jewish buffer
they were allowed to other
and all the nefarious
things that were happening
in the society onto that Jewish community.
That was the Pilgrims
of the 1800s in earlier,
in Europe.
Well, that same theory of change
still functions here in the U.S.
and it's often why we see it.
But I wanna say something else.
We also have to acknowledge,
that even as we condemn antisemitism,
that unconscious racial
bias, anti-Blackness,
plays out in these conversations, right?
It doesn't make us bad to admit
that these different dynamics
are happening at the same time.
I can tell you as a person
who wrote his first essay
on antisemitism back in like 1992, '91,
that Black folks who
stumble on antisemitism,
receive a different level of response
than non-Black folks who
make similar stumbles.
I'm thinking right now of...
I'm spacing on his name
right now, so apologies.
The NFL player, DeSean Jackson,
who made some really incredible,
horrifying antisemitic statements
on Twitter
and to the press.
You know, during that same week,
Madonna said something
offensive and antisemitic,
so did Chelsea Handler, I think it was,
excuse me if I got that wrong,
said something equally atrocious,
but there was only one
person who received attention
and that was DeSean Jackson.
That is the unconscious
bias that exists in society.
Now look, I'm not saying DeSean Jackson
didn't deserve that attention.
What I'm saying,
is that if you're going
to give that attention
to Black perpetrators of antisemitism,
make sure you're giving the
same equal treatment and heat,
to white perpetrators.
If we don't do that,
we're creating wedges.
But on the racial justice side,
if we dabble in antisemitic
tropes, if we aren't disciplined
in understanding that
antisemitism is a form of racism
and if we are about racial
justice, if we're anti-racist,
we have to oppose all
forms of racial justice,
we are also creating wedges,
wedges between two communities
that have traditionally been the bedrock
of civil rights in this
country since the 1950s.
We each have to be more
responsible, stop pointing fingers
and understanding that all of us function
in an unconscious bias society.
It doesn't make us bad people.
What makes us bad people is being too lazy
to learn what these are so
that we can try to avoid them
because our children deserve that from us.
- Thank you so much, Eric.
I think we're gonna leave it there.
I wanna thank you for
alerting us to what you call
these stumbles over the last 30 years
that, of course, you've been
working so hard to address
across three decades now and
doing so much for all of us,
for helping us to understand
better what's now at stake,
the importance of thinking
about antisemitism
within broader concerns about democracy
in the United States and
worldwide and about anti-racism
as a fundamental concern
of all of us and why,
in your words, it's important
to show up in the right ways
when it comes to antisemitism
as a core concern for all of us.
Let me just underscore
for everyone who's here
that Eric's writings are posted
on Medium as he mentioned
and I'd encourage folks to
read those articles carefully,
where I think you'll find
even more to think about
and answers some of the questions
we weren't able to get to here verbally.
Let me thank, in conclusion, my colleagues
at Yale Center for the
Study of Race, Indigeneity
and Transnational Migration and also
the Yale Program for the
Study of Antisemitism,
especially my colleague, Maurice Samuels.
Eric, thank you so much
for your leadership,
for your presence here today.
And we'll look to you in the years to come
to continue to be a
leader on these questions
and so many others.
Thank you.
- I look forward.
Thank you so much.